[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente chers collègues
madame la Première ministre la montée
des actes antisémites des agressions
contre nos compatriotes Juifs les PO
grames auxquels nous avons assisté en
Israël avec les attaques terroristes du
Hamas nous rappellent que l'ignominie
des hommes et les idéologie de haine
sont prêtes à surgir dès que nous
baissons la garde dès que la défense du
bien plie devant la faiblesse dès que le
souci de l'avenir cède à l'imprécision
l'imprévision en faisant le choix
inconsidéré de faire rentrer en France
sans discernement ni contrôle des
millions d'immigrés la classe politique
a aussi fait entrer et même organiser
l'entrée dans notre pays de gens
prosélites porteurs d'une idéologie
sanguinaire
l'islamisme que l'on soit bien clair je
ne confonds pas les musulmans qui
pratiquent leur religion de manière
paisible et fraternelle avec les
islamistes de la même manière je ne
confonds pas les PAL en avec le Hamas
qui s'en sert comme bouclier humain face
au fléau de l'antisémitisme le pays a a
opposé par une manifestation unitaire et
particulièrement digne dont chacun doit
se féliciter la démonstration de sa
réprobation absolue face à ce qui touche
à l'essentiel toute division devient un
acte de complicité
objective pour autant parce que nous le
devons à l'histoire parce que nous le
devons aux victimes de cette barbarie
mais aussi pour l'avenir parce que nous
le devons à nos enfants les
protestations aussi éploré que fortes
soit-elles ne ne suffisent pas elles ne
feront reculer aucun fanatique aucun
prêcheur de haine aucun idiot utile de
l'islamisme pourtant force de constater
au vu des dernières déclarations de
membres du gouvernement ou de la
majorité que vous n'osez même pas
désigner l'idéologie qui soutend la
haine antisémitisme et qui parfois arme
la main des on ne combat pas on ne
combat pas une menace quand on est
incapable de la nommer madame la
Première ministre qu'alz-vous faire pour
combattre
l'islam la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
verrand ministre en charge du renouveau
démocratique et porte parole du
[Applaudissements]
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la présidente madame la
députée Pascale borde
Koulibali Mohamed Mera et de nombreux
autres djihadistes ont commis des
attentats antisémite sur notre sol au
nom de l'idéologie islamiste et cela
personne ne le nit le gouvernement lutte
avec acharnement
contre le gouvernement monsieur le
député
platur encore une fois je vous rappelle
à l'ordre le gouvernement lutte avec
détermination évidment contre le
fanatismes monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement lutte avec
détermination contre le radicalisme
islamiste qui tue contre le radicalisme
islamiste qui commet des actes
antisémites le gouvernement madame la
députée vous avez commencé par poser une
question sur l'antisémitisme et vous la
termz par la lutte contre l'islamisme en
réalité le
gouvernement le gouvernement lutte avec
détermin tion contre toutes les formes
d'antisémitisme lutte avec détermination
contre toutes les idéologies mortifères
qui visent à diviser les Français les
uns contre les autres toutes les
idéologies d'où qu'elles viennent qui
mettent en insécurité nos concitoyens
juifs il y en a hélas madame la députée
en dehors du cadre de l'islam et nous ne
négligeons pas et ce que les Français
ont été nombreux à dire à Paris à
Grenoble à Toulouse et dans beaucoup de
ville de France dimanche c'est que
l'antisémitisme les antisémitismes il y
en a pas un bon et un mauvais madame la
es C fores d'antisémi qui gang notre
société n pas notre n pas leur place en
France et croyez en notre détermination
pour lutter contre je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre